Good morning, Hank; it's Wednesday. Today,
I'm going to try to re-carbon-neutralize the
vlogbrothers, but first three notes...
Number One: I loved your interview with the
mayor of Missoula; I wish that he could be
my mayor without me having to move to Missoula.
Number Two: Hank, it was a year ago today
that our friend and Ningmaster, Tom, almost
died in a bicycle accident, and was in a coma
forever, but then he didn't die, and now he's
here, and yay!
And Number Three, Hank: I should probably
button this button. We're running a video
blog here, not a porn studio.
Okay, Hank, so in October of 2007, I carbon-neutralized
Nerdfighteria at a cost of, like, 30 bucks.
So I figured I'd do it again even though we
now have slightly more views. By the way,
if you don't believe that carbon dioxide emissions
contribute to climate change, that's... fine.
Okay, so vlogbrothers videos have been viewed
about 122 million times; the average video
length is around 3 minutes and 30 seconds.
Of course, lots of people don't watch the
entire video... I mean, particularly the giraffe
sex videos; they get there and they're like,
"Where's the giraffe sex? There's no giraffe
sex! It's just a guy; he's talking. He's not
very funny; he's got funny hair. I hate this
guy! Click!"
But then again, Nerdfighteria does a lot of
things other than watch videos like create
profiles on the Ning, and post in Your Pants,
and post YouTube comments... so let's just
take a wild guess and say that it averages
out to 3 minutes and 30 seconds, because that's
a good number for calculation and I'm pretty
bad at math, so I need help.
Okay, so 122 million times 3.5 is... really?
427 million minutes?
Now, Hank, because I've seen the musical "Rent,"
I know there are 525,600 minutes in a year,
which means that Nerdfighteria is more than
812 years old!
By the way, Hank, speaking of the amazing
things Nerdfighteria can do because it's 812
years old: Did you know that there are nerdfighters
in Your Pants currently trying to figure out
the mystery of Gussie Manlove, Walter Manlove's
wife? Link in the dooblydoo.
So, Hank, we're talking about a total of about
7,116,667 hours. It takes an average of 120
watts per hour for computers to browse the
Internet, so you multiply that big number
times 120, and you get... 854 million, zero
thousand, forty watts. Did I say that number
right? God, I'm bad at math.
Which is 854,000.04 kilowatts, but I'm going
to eliminate that "zero-four," Hank, because
it makes the math hard.
On average, in the US, it takes about 1.35
pounds of carbon to create a kilowatt of energy,
ergo... Nerdfighteria is responsible for 1,152,900
pounds of carbon, which means, Hank, that
Nerdfighteria, in four years, has created
more carbon emissions than the average Swede
will in his or her lifetime.
That's right, Hank. Nerdfighteria is already...
a Swede.
And let me remind you, Hank, Nerdfighteria
is not even a person; it's an idea.
On the upside, Hank, I already got rid of
23,000 pounds of our carbon emissions in 2007,
which means that now we only have 1.13 million
pounds of carbon to offset. It would take
just over $5,000 to offset our carbon emissions
at carbonfund.org, but I'm not going to do
that, Hank, uh, because someday, Henry is
gonna want to go to college.
But, Hank, when you think about the fact that
Nerdfighteria is responsible for one million
pounds of carbon emissions and the vast majority
of people have never even heard the word "Nerdfighteria,"
it begins to give you a sense of how huge
the problem we're facing really is. I mean,
if you think about YouTube's carbon emissions,
you're talking about trillions of pounds of
carbon.
I still think YouTube is awesome; I certainly
think Nerdfighteria is awesome, but Hank,
we need to be aware of the price of that awesome.
I'll see you on Friday.
Nerdfighters from Bahrain to New Zealand to
Libya to Morocco are experiencing mega-worldsuck
for a lot of different reasons. And so, Nerdfighteria,
I just want to encourage you, first, to pay
attention, and second, to help where you can.
There are some links in the dooblydoo.